Під димовою завісою - абордаж судна. У воді напоготові водолази зі зброєю.
Це одна з багатьох спецоперацій у рамках Sea Breeze-2021.
Цьогорічні навчання - наймасштабніші за всю історію військових маневрів, що вперше відбулися ще 1997-го року.
У навчаннях взяли участь понад п’ять тисяч військових із 32 країн, 40 літаків, 32 кораблі та 18 команд спецоперацій і дайвінгу.
Усі вони відпрацьовували дії як на морі, так і на суші. Від Одеси й Очакова до Дністровського лиману та дельти Дунаю.
Мета наших навчань - це підтримка миру та стабільності в чорноморському регіоні і забезпечення безпеки цивільного, в першу чергу, судноплавства.
Російська Федерація не розуміє взагалі порядку застосування норм міжнародного морського права
і поводить себе як агресор і розраховує, що Чорне море та Азовське море - це її зона відповідальності і зона впливу.
У відповідь Росія теж провела навчання і погатила зі своїх кораблів по умовному ворогу.
В пресі також писали, що під виглядом тренування начебто відпрацьовувалось і бомбардування кораблів. Американці відреагували спокійно.
Ми діємо у міжнародних водах. Усі ці навчання відбуваються у міжнародних водах і в територіальних водах України.
Що стосується морської реакції Російської Федерації, то треба запитати росіян.
Зі свого боку ми будемо продовжувати працювати безпечно та професійно взаємодіяти з нашими партнерами та російськими суднами.
У російських пропагандистських ЗМІ поширюється думка, що навчання "Сі Бриз" збільшують напругу в Чорному морі, провокуючи Росію.
Експерти ж вказують навпаки - на агресивні спроби Кремля домінувати у чорноморському регіоні, мілітаризуючи Крим шаленими темпами.
З точки зору провокації Росії: Росії не потрібна була провокація в 2008 році напасти на маленьку беззахисну Грузію,
і не було абсолютно жодних підстав з українського боку, щоби напасти на Україну, анексувати Крим, почати війну в Донецьку і Луганську.
Росія впродовж часу від анексії мілітаризувала Крим до шалених розмірів,
і це за великим рахунком є найбільш боєздатна частина і з точки зору сухопутного компоненту, і морського компоненту.
Кількість крилатих ракет "Калібр", які розміщені на російських підводних човнах і на малих катерах і кораблях,
достатня для того, щоб фактично знищити європейський континент, оскільки ці крилаті ракети можуть нести і бойовий заряд.
До речі, з 2014 року відбувається відновлення сховищ ядерних матеріалів і боєзарядів на території Криму,
і є підозри, що Російська Федерація вже використовує їх за прямим призначенням.
Тобто всі ці речі були спочатку, а потім вже була повільна реакція Заходу,
повільна реакція країн регіону для того, щоб убезпечити себе від можливої російської агресії.
Тобто причина і наслідки тут абсолютно інші.
Поступово країни чорноморського регіону та їхні партнери вже роблять відповідні висновки,
зважаючи на дії Росії, і співпраця значно посилюється.
Ось так, приміром, на Херсонщині відпрацьовували черговий етап злагодження батальйону тактичної групи,
яка представлена підрозділами України, США, Грузії та Молдови, а також Державної прикордонної служби.
Це, зокрема, завдання вогневої підготовки та штурмових дій.
Навчання були чудові. Це була прекрасна можливість співпрацювати з країнами-партнерами.
Мої морські піхотинці отримали величезну кількість тренувань.
А це вже Миколаївщина. Підготовка десанту.
Група спецпризначення була виведена в умовний тил противника на 10 кілометрів у повній екіпіровці та зі штатним озброєнням.
Українські спецпризначенці набувають досвід американських колег.
Де краще сісти, як краще вистрибнути, яке краще положення прийняти, які особливості взагалі при підйомах-спусках і так далі.
Дуже багато нюансів. Це все можна отримати тільки з досвідом.
У них відповідно досвіду набагато більше, і відповідно знають вони більше.
Американці знають і вміють більше, але в разі ескалації конфлікту з Росією військовим шляхом НАТО не допоможе.
5 стаття північноатлантичного договору про колективну безпеку не поширюється на країни, що не є членами Альянсу.
Але навчання на кшталт "Сі Бриз" є фактором стримування Росії.
Є політично-дипломатична підтримка, і ми бачили це, коли своїми м'язами на нашому кордоні,
на окупованій території Росія грала і намагалася примусити, по-перше, Україну погодитися з її трактуванням Мінських домовленостей,
але, найголовніше, здобути увагу у Вашингтоні. Це політико-дипломатичний трек, можна сказати так.
Друга частина - це, безумовно, присутність нечорноморських країн НАТО в Чорному морі, яка посилилася з 2014 року.
Зараз цей процес набуває обертів і це надзвичайно позитивна річ.
Третій момент - стратегічні документи НАТО змінюються, є розуміння, що загальна стратегія оборони східного флангу має бути переглянута,
і посилений південний напрям. Далі, безумовно, коли відбуваються навчання, чи є присутність британських чи американських есмінців,
то російська нахабність у Чорному морі значно зменшується.
Тому це є стабілізаційним фактором для того, щоб Росія не вдавалася до певних авантюр.
А далі, безумовно, це взаємосумісність і співпраця між нашими збройними силами, військово-морськими силами і країнами НАТО,
це обмін розвідінформацією, це й інші речі, які потрібні нам, щоб вдосконалитися і щоб бути більш складною мішенню
для Російської Федерації, якщо вони вирішать піти на широкомасштабну операцію або якусь операцію в Чорному морі.
Українські військові разом з колегами з понад 30 країн відпрацювали різноманітні дії -
від протиповітряної оборони до морського протистояння за стандартами і процедурами НАТО.
За словами експертів, навчання "Сі Бриз" нині мають особливе значення,
оскільки дають політичний сигнал Москві, що ніхто не збирається погоджуватися з анексією Криму,
і, по-друге, визнавати повзучу анексію українських територіальних вод навколо півострова.